the men that work for me  must be capable of violence  why are we burning this place it's  called sending a message  he trusts you and trust is a valuable  commodity  gabe doesn't just work for you he's your  friend  i really want the respect that comes  with this job it ain't respect it's fear  i'm sorry to disturb you what are you  talking about i'm the distraction  your boss has got another job for you  he's being taken care of  he made us i'm bringing him in  onwards and upwards  hey boss we have a possible witness just  get rid of the cop  [Music]  what do you want  get in or you're dead i'm tendering my  resignation  i'm gonna hunt you down what are we  going to do  you're a mob soldier and i'm a cop  well i've got guns  a lot of guns  i'm taking that lady cop back to mr  solomon  okay  just get rid of them full whatever the  cost you got boss  i have learned one truth  criminals  are their own worst enemy look at me  [ __ ]  [Music]  you